[Music]
joining me now to unpack all of this is
John lauro attorney for president Donald
J Trump he was there in the courtroom
today John um they want this trial to be
speedy this was repeated all day long on
the other cable networks they wanted to
happen before the election what does
that tell you tonight
it tells me everything Laura about
what's going on about the attack on our
constitution I've talked a lot about how
this is criminalized First Amendment
speech because president Trump like all
of us has a right to redress grievances
as a right to protest an election that
he felt was unfair has a right to
campaign on a position and they've
attacked that right not just for
president Trump but for everyone but now
today in court which was a very terribly
sad day
they're attacking other parts of the
Constitution because they want to take
president Trump to trial in a few months
they want to deny him his sixth
amendment rights to council to give me
and my co-counsel Todd Blanche an
opportunity to prepare they want to deny
president Trump his due process rights
to look at documents to get witnesses to
use our subpoena power
they want to deny all of him those
rights in a rush to judgment for one
political purpose and that's to uphold
the Biden Administration make no mistake
about it this has Merrick Garland's
handiwork all around it this case was
brought had to be approved by Merrick
Garland and interestingly enough
why the bums Rush on this case do they
feel that there's a problem in the other
cases that are being orchestrated and
they need to bring this case to trial in
a couple of months in this venue
what does that tell you well they
definitely don't want to name any of the
other co-conspirators correct because
that would slow them down I mean if this
was such a assault on our Democratic
process which obviously it was not Trump
left office voluntarily the electors you
know had the you know vote certified all
of that so that all happened
but they actually want this to go
forward as fast as possible and so
they'll let go of the co-conspirators
correct that's 100
this is a this is a fast-moving railroad
without any concern for justice speedy
trial rights are a defendant's speedy
trial rights a citizen's speedy trial
rights not the government the government
has an obligation to ensure a fair trial
and in this case what we need is a
journey to the truth not not a
railroading of a of an American citizen
let alone a former president so what we
have here is a strategic move by the
Biden Administration to get to trial as
quickly as possible because for whatever
reason and we know the reason they think
they can do better here in the District
of Columbia than they can do in a more
diverse State like Florida well they
mean I think that's a harder argument
for you to for you to argue because it's
it is very difficult to change venue and
in these types of cases it hasn't been
successful but I think you're on to
something about what they want to
prevent they want they want to prevent
the people from having their say next
year whatever that say is Bill Barr the
former Attorney General no love loss
obviously between Trump and Barr he
disagrees with the Free Speech defense
and this is why
they're not attacking his first
amendment right he can say whatever he
wants he can even lie that does not
protect you from entering into a
conspiracy all conspiracies involve
speech and all fraud involves speech so
uh you know Free Speech doesn't give you
the right to engage in a fraudulent
conspiracy
John your response to that laughable
absolutely laughable what's the fraud
tell me what the fraud is what's the
fraudulent speech Donald Trump president
Trump was out in the open petitioning
the state legislatures petitioning the
courts there was nothing fraudulent
going on this is absolutely protected
First Amendment speech for Mr Barr to
say that is a complete and utter and
utter ignorance of what the basic law is
with respect to freedom of speech the
first amendment protects not only speech
but it protects the right to protest and
it protects the right to petition for
grievances which president Trump did to
characterize this as fraud when there's
nothing being done in secret there's
nothing being hidden there's nothing to
see yeah John they're hanging it all or
a lot of it on the supposed conversation
between Pence and Trump that Pence took
contamin contempt notes of where Trump
said you're too honest from paraphrasing
but yeah you're just too honest but I
mean to me that's just a throwaway line
that doesn't prove anything but man
they're hanging a lot on that one phrase
good luck I'm ready for them at trial I
can't wait but but something about the
conversations between Mr Pence and Mr
Trump
president Trump was getting advice from
an esteemed constitutional scholar as to
an array of options that he could take
in light of the discrepancies and what
was going on in 2020 those discrepancies
were well known and and they were being
litigated Professor Eastman laid out a
series of options that were discussed
with vice president Pence
vice president Pence disagreed on
certain issues but ultimately what
president Trump said is let's go with
option D let's just halt let's just
pause the voting and allow the state
legislatures to take one last look and
make a determination as to the as to
whether or not the elections were
handled fairly that's constitutional law
that's not an issue of of criminal
activity
it's John um August 28th is the next
date that you guys are supposed to
appear or you'll you'll appear for the
next hearing um thank you we're going to
be following this we really appreciate
you joining us tonight now hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else